the bomb is really bomb I know it really
is they're not lying when they have that
oh my
God hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Sydney Sweeney
she's an mem awward nominated actress
you know from breakout hit shows like
White Lotus the handmade stale and
Euphoria as well as a year in film that
includes anyone but you reality and more
now though she's taking on the role of
Julia Carpenter and Madam Webb the
latest from the spiderverse set to
release in theaters on February 14th
Sydney Sweeney welcome to the show thank
you what's going through your head as
you prepare to take on the hot ones
lineup are you at all nervous going into
this I am so nervous I am shaking right
now this is going to I am I am this is
terrifying for
me
[Music]
all
right that was PR
[Music]
good I think I psyched myself too high
and I'm good okay I got this I can see
so there's been so much building
anticipation for your performance in
Madam web especially so since the first
images of you and the Spiderwoman suit
leaked to the internet November do you
remember where you were and what was
going through your head when you tried
on the costume and ey mask for the first
time yes I was in Boston already we we
filmed in Boston and we had like this
really cool scan done of our body so
they could get like a full 3d
measurement of us and they showed us
sketches and I was like oh my God that's
so cool cuzz it had like full 3d
sketches of our faces and when I put it
on I truly I felt like a superhero it
was the coolest thing
ever oh
dear M it doesn't feel as spicy as the
other one we're like lulling you into a
false sense of security over here yeah
that's not as
spicy shifting gears on you Sydney
playing all kinds of Mind Games yeah I
wasn't that wasn't spicy at all there we
go shrugging it off okay you got this
all along okay this is not bad so I know
that you've been an avid Bookworm since
childhood which now as someone who owns
a production company serves this Dual
Purpose as being a powerful pipeline to
the big screen what are the elements
that make a novel a prime candidate for
adaptation and are there any telltale
signs that let you know it'll be an
uphill climb yeah you know there's a lot
of different variables that go into if I
like a book or not whether I connect to
the the character if it's moving how
it's developed if there's a amazing Arc
to that character or the story itself um
or if I'm just interested in it
sometimes I just find a whole story
interesting and I'm like there's
something there I can take a concept of
that and twist it into something else
and I'll find it that way what's the uh
best book you read this year ooh the
best book I've read you know I read
Clara in the sun it was really good
there we go possible adaptation there
I think so all right so this one's got a
little sweet a little Savory
[Music]
okay not spicy at
all I thought this was hot ones oh I
remember you said
that okay doing research about you you
know I saw this story over and over
again about your prep process and how
you'll do these character biographies
mhm of the characters you've played
which 100-page Journal do you think
would be like the best seller as a
personal
Memoir ooh probably Cassie Cassie's book
is really really cool it's the most
developed cuz I've had so much time with
her yeah you had like the whole summer
to do it right well the whole summer and
then also there's been I have two
seasons of her so she's grown so much
and I was able to have season 1 and then
season two and just kind of De this book
so it's really cool to just see how it
changes where do you keep all the
character Bibles like are they in a box
somewhere are they on a shelf they're in
a shelf in a box and there's there's a
there's a sign that says Sydney do not
touch it's not spicy do you even have
taste buds in I don't know it might all
be just scorched Earth actually back
here right but I have to say you must be
impressing yourself a little bit at this
point I'm really impressing myself right
now I'm very
proud I am too very impressed from this
side of the table thank you thank you
what are the mechanics of throwing up on
camera like that scene in season 2 of
euphoria in the hot tub that's one of
the most realistic puking scenes I've
ever seen on TV so there was a lot of
work that went behind that they had to
create because Sam wanted of course it
just to be projectile vomit everywhere
where a lot of films they'll just have a
cup of mushed up anything that they have
from crafty mixed with milk and water
and the most disgusting thing and you
just put it in your mouth and you hold
it and then you puke it up but Sam of
course did not want that he just wanted
vomit everywhere so they had to get a
pump and and they had this pipe that
they just taped and hid all my body and
then they CGI it out up my neck and then
there was a horse bit that I had to put
in my mouth and so during that scene
they're filling my mouth with throw up
and then I and then I open my mouth and
it just starts shooting out of my mouth
and it was the most disgusting thing
I've ever experienced this is the movie
Magic behind the scenes topics these are
the things that we like to dive in here
but I think that was important because
what you're saying is Right everyone has
the cup but then you don't really get
the realistic volume you need volume you
need the pump it's a very insane pump
too but the horse bit it was so I was
like why do I need the horse bit it was
[Music]
huge interesting okay we'll
see interesting
[Music]
choice yeah who's going to drink first
ooh it's a
standoff well you know what now that the
Line in the Sand has been drawn I'm
going to hold my ground oh really we'll
see who drinks first Sydney
okay see not only star and executive
have produced the 2023 romcom anyone but
you but I know also spent a year working
on a spec script and it's clear that you
have an affinity for that early 2000s
feel good love story that Hollywood used
to make a lot more often what to you are
the Hallmarks of a good romantic comedy
like when they work what makes them work
I think when you
have two characters
who you fall in love with and you want
them to fall in love also um I love
aamcom that you leave the theater and
you have laughed you've cried you want
to go and fall absolutely head over
heels in love uh that's what makes a
really good romcom off the top of your
head and without thinking about it too
much what is Sydney Sweeney's goat
romcom I'm not even lying when I say
It's My Best Friend's Wedding which was
so cool because we got to see it with
dermit and he hadn't seen that movie
since the premiere and it was the most
special beautiful experience all right
we are halfway done believe it or not
wow not a sweat broke I know I can't
believe it this next one is the bourbon
Maple Reaper in the six spot Reaper
which is important also this one's way
darker than the other ones that's when
you know it's getting serious over
here are are you trying to cool it down
there's nothing you can do I reflexively
do that but it doesn't help all
right
yeah I'm good I'm good I knew
it is someone whose hobbies include MMA
training dirt bikes wakeboarding and
operating on heavy machinery what's the
worst injury you've ever suffered at the
hands of your hobbies oh so I when I was
I think I was 11 or 12 I look back cuz
my mom's here yeah yeah um I got yeah I
think I was 11 or 12 uh I got on a
wakeboarding accident and the board came
up and sliced my face and I have a scar
right here next to my eye and I had to
get a bunch of stitches that was the
worst accident ever but when I got my
stitches out my mom took me back out to
the lake and put me back in the water
and I'm screaming and crying cuz I did
not want to get back up on the board I
was terrified and she would not let me
leave until I stood back up well shout
out to Mom yeah when you fall off that
horse get back up you got to get back up
yeah how about this uh which
extracurricular of your youth do you
remember more fondly robotic team or the
academic Club math is
cool how do you know
this
um oh my God I don't know which one I
would say is my favorite I think math is
cool I fell in love with math you know
why cuz it's cool exactly CU it's
[__] cool because it's [__]
cool how did you find that out yeah wait
you're Sydney Sweeny we have to know
shout out nard War oh my God all right
are you ready to move on here to is
sauce number seven yes so here we have a
forbidden fruit
okay mhm I see kind of a contemplative
look on your face well I'm trying to
figure out where I'm supposed to taste
the
[Laughter]
spice
damn I'm really confused right now well
we'll check on the next one the next one
will be a good stress test for this
whole thing but maybe you got to get
into Carolina Reaper eating competitions
or something you know if the acting
thing doesn't work out I'll just like
travel around different fairs this is
the talent inside you all along I had no
idea so the fashion of euphoria is so
influential that it spawned its own
coffee table book what would you say
distinguishes the approach of costume
designer Heidi Biven oo I think that she
has approached each character with such
a unique Vision that she allows all of
us to also bring our own ideas to the
table which is really cool is there a
backstory to the jam out with your clam
out tea that you wore on White
Lotus
um
no how about this what to you is
fundamental or key when picking out the
perfect bucket hat oh you know I
actually really like bucket hats if it
fits my head yeah just shape do you have
an all-time favorite stylist pull that
you've been able to walk off set with
and work into rotation
ooh I always take uh all of my stylus
things usually jackets purses
shoes if you're going to take the time
to tailor them you might as well right I
don't get it I do not understand we
tailor these outfits we do this whole
thing I don't know how it fits everybody
else and then I have to give it back
makes me sad it's not fair it's just
going to go into storage I'll wear it
again all right Sydney mhm you have
walked right along this chicken wing
line okay unaffected yes unfaced okay
this next one is the bomb Beyond
Insanity ooh we go out with the old in
with the new every year okay except for
this sauce which has held its ground
since basically the beginning why you're
about to find
out
[Music]
okay that pretty good what
wow I mean I feel tingly on my lips yeah
I that one might have an after effect
yeah and builds a little bit but that
one's building in my mouth yeah
yeah it's all right we got this yeah
that one's building M what it why it
doesn't stop either I I think it's just
um something about it you know wow and
there aren't a lot of great redeeming
culinary qualities about it either so
it's kind of just like straight taking
gasoline or something you know yeah yeah
all right finally I was
worried wow I know is your tongue num my
my throat is uh I can't even feel it you
know what I mean that's number what
eight which is good why is this
happening because it just it's what
happens and this is where I'll say be
careful on the eyes you know you'll have
like a natural kind of um urge a natural
impulse to wipe your eyes try not to WIP
my eyes all right
so earlier this year what is in this I
it's
just I don't know maybe like amounts of
poison cuz I won't drink it first no I'm
stand I'm standing up I'm 10 toes I'm on
10 toes right
here so earlier this year are you
talking it's just a lot of practice I've
had a lot of practice but you did a GQ
10 Things I can't live without video and
opened it perhaps joking perhaps not
about eating Kit Kats for breakfast and
then sprinkling Sour Patch Kids in your
popcorn so that you have about that
surprise when you eat no I get it I get
it I wish I had an ice cream show I
really do but this is the cross that I
bear over
here do you have a Mount Rushmore of
movie theater candies a top four sugary
snacks to pair with film yes I
do I like um
AirHeads um I like peanut M&M's I like
sour PCH kids
and
wow uh Kit Kats with Madam Webb dropping
on Valentine's Day do you have a take or
a position on Candy Hearts I love
them the bomb is really bomb I know it
really is they're not lying when they
have that oh my God but you know what I
think this is a healthy reaction you
know what you had going on before this
was maybe more concerning than this you
know I think that they all just waited
to kick it all at the same time yeah the
cumulative effect unlocked it all and
you know what I think they heard you
popping [__] about them I think so you
know I think that that's really what
happened and then all of a sudden you
needed this uh Revenge Arc God damn
people are going to just come at me in
the comments now they're not they're not
they're going to be so inspired by your
Bravery here
[Music]
yeah how do you feel about moving on
here I feel great let's do it I love
that attitude you know I'm catching
secondhand enthusiasm over
and I think it's given me the strength
that I
[Music]
need is this another deadly killer
anything that you eat after the bomb
yeah is just a little bit easier yeah
exactly it kind of clears everybody out
the paint and allows for smooth sailing
not fun by any stretch of imagination
but no you got it oh that's good is it
true that you briefly worked as a tour
guide at Universal Studios and if so did
you have a favorite tour fun fact or
point of Interest I used to do the
architecture tour of the Chicago River
in Lake Michigan so share a natural
kinship in the profession that's so cool
yeah no um I you know was a struggling
actor in high school and I had to pay
all my own bills cuz my mom I mean I
love you Mom I love you so much um but
yeah I'd pay my phone bill car insurance
uh everything gas uh and I'm so glad she
did cuz I've learned how to budget and
save my money and and know what's
important in life um I always I love
tour guides at Universal I memorize the
entire thing and so I was there for a
little bit and then I actually booked um
sharp objects that's a great exit
strategy I was I was out there on that
River and Lake for like six years like
six Summers I used to have
dreams where i' do the entire shift that
I just did in my dream and then go back
to doing tours that's the one thing
about running Dre about this but the
good thing is Sydney Sweeney yeah the
night nightmare is almost
over well if you're doing I have to do
it there we go oh
shoot just be careful stey
hands I'm already
joking I pour too much do you want to
switch do you want to trade nope respect
you know what then I'll add a little
extra too I I just you know I I want the
same wavelength over here I'm going to
even it out there you go SL spread
okay ready
[Music]
yep
incredible mhm and like I said nothing
fun about that
nope but we're here at the end and to
close things out what I want to do is
just a quick rapid fire travel guide
okay for someone who grew up near the
border of Washington and Idaho it's the
first time we've ever had a guest with
that situation okay first things first
summer at the lake do I need to go to
cordal lane or S Point ooh summertime
quarter line huckleberry picking
overrated or underrated love it there
you go properly rated and then finally a
favorite local mountain to ski is it
schwitzer schwitzer but I was I was
actually I was on the ski team at M
Spokan yeah well you know what it would
be nice to be on the snow tipped
mountain peak right now yes it would but
you know what it's all over the worst is
over Sydney Sweeney taking on the wings
of death living to tell the tale and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life um
I'm I'm just hoping I don't die by
tomorrow um I got a movie that's coming
out called Madam web it's really cool
you should go see
it my lips are going
numb
all right now yeah Cheers Cheers let's
drink it's time
[Music]
cheers oh why didn't we do that sooner
we should have done that way earlier wow
it's good right thanks for bringing this
in first time on that that works yeah
frapuccino I'm really [__] proud of
myself you should be proud of yourself I
thought I was going to die made it
through well only time will'll tell but
I it's looking good yeah it's looking
good okay that was
insane hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans thank you so much for
watching today's episode and if you
would like to get the taste of hot ones
delivered right to your door well I have
good news for you the season 23 hot ones
10 pack is available now heatness.com
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the season 23 hot ones
lineup milk that included ice cream
highly recommended and
remember be careful around the
eyes